Speaker 1: Brian Stelter is out of a job at CNN
with the network deciding to cancel his weekend
program. Reliable Sources, a show
that's been on the air for 30 years,
the last nine of which Brian Stelter hosted. And
this is part of CNN's attempts to rebrand itself.
We know that CNN used to try to play the role
of being a down the line corporate media outlet,
positioning itself as the rational center between
Fox News on the right and MSNBC on the left,
going with the most trusted name in news,
Monica. Then the Trump years rolled around
and they shifted into being a more outwardly
anti-Trump network, more opinionated, becoming a
lot more just like an MSNBC alternative. But now,
with some changes over at CNN with Jeff Zucker,
out with Chris Cuomo, out with CNN. Plus, failing
miserably. They have the room to make some image
changes and it looks like they're going back
in the direction of being a more hard news
down the line network. And I'm sure they'll still
be worthy of plenty of criticism, right, because
they probably will continue to try to be neutral
instead of objective. They'll be too corporate,
too sensationalist, focus on two stories. But
to me at least, I do think that this makes sense
for them to go in this direction because there
seems to be more market share trying to be the
centrist news outlet with so many other cable
news outlets being left or right. And it seems
like the change is largely being influenced
by John Malone, who is the most powerful
investor over at Warner Brothers Discovery Inc.
That's the parent company of CNN. And Malone is a
right slash libertarian guy. He's not a Trumpist,
but he's definitely a conservative. He actually
likes to watch Fox News, reportedly. And I don't
know if you've seen this, but over at Fox, they
absolutely love to bash Brian Stelter whenever
given the opportunity. So it makes sense that
after seeing all that Fox News that Malone
would want to go in the direction of ousting
Brian Stelter in favor of someone else. And,
you know, just with the network trying to make
all these changes, generally there was just no
room for Stelter, unfortunately for him. And then
there's also the money angle, too, right? Because
Stelter was reportedly making almost $1,000,000 a
year, despite the fact that his show was only
getting 500000 to 600000 viewers per episode.
So looking at the business side of things, it just
doesn't seem to add up. And final point I wanted
to make on this. I do like the idea of having a
media literacy show out there, something with the
idea of being focused on the media, a watchdog
for the media. But is CNN the right place to
have a show like this? Because you can't pretend
to be the arbiter of good journalistic practices
when it comes to other networks, when you yourself
at your network are also going to be victims of
the same sort of biases and problems. Right.
You're just not in a position where you have
the credibility to do a show like that. And it
often would create this conflict of interest where
you don't cover your same your own network with
the same sort of scrutiny that you'll cover other
networks. Like I remember when CNN Plus failed,
Stelter went on the airwaves that he talked about
how it was really too early to tell whether or not
CNN Plus was a success because it only made it a
couple of weeks or a couple of days, whatever it
was. And so it was just too early to tell. Well,
if MSNBC or Fox News's streaming network failed
so early, would he have had the same commentary? I
don't think so. Something tells me his takes would
have been a little bit different. And of course,
you can just decide not to cover what's
going on at your network at all. So it
created all these conflicts. I just don't
think that CNN was the right place for it.
And that is the latest reliable source is
canceled after 30 years, the last nine of
which Brian Stelter hosted. And now he's out
of a job looking for somewhere else to work